the place is rostov-on-don two men
waiting in a line for beer get into an
argument with each other
what made it particularly interesting to
the world is that they were arguing
about this man's philosophy Immanuel
Kant and what made that particularly
interesting is that Kant would have been
totally against what they were doing so
you wonder what's actually going on we
don't know that much more of the story
beyond the fact that one of them pulled
the gun and shot the other one full of
rubber bullets so for me this is a
particularly interesting news story
that's I would say at the risk of
becoming a meme that's gonna be around
on the internet for a while I'm sure
that somebody has already started to put
together captions with pictures of Kant
and maybe these guys and beer something
along those lines
why is it such an interesting story is
it just sort of the famous for being
famous kind of phenomenon there's a lot
of people posting about it we don't
actually know all that much about what
took place because the news reports are
basically just recycling the same bits
of information including the one really
important bit of information which is
that we don't actually know what these
guys were arguing about having to do
with [__] we don't even know if these
guys understood caught adequately or if
they were you know zeroing in on one
particular exegetical point in some
treaties that they both knew quite well
but it is a really interesting story for
me four four five different reasons one
is that it became a story at all and
I'll talk about that in just a moment
another is that these guys actually came
to blows so I you know went through a
number of different stages over over
some interpretation of Immanuel Kant in
his philosophy or the importance of it
another thing that was kind of
interesting they came out is this notion
that it's common to argue and get heated
about
ideas in Russia that that's part of the
culture and that's worth reflecting on a
little bit the fourth thing is that
clearly this is completely to both from
anything that cut stood for believed in
thought about it goes contrary to so
much in conch and philosophy I'll talk a
bit about that and then the fifth thing
is that Kant has some really interesting
things to say although not in great
depth not in deep analysis about not
just you know why this would be wrong
how it wouldn't fit the categorical
imperative but about the workings of the
human soul with respect to the emotions
and the passions and our duties to in
broad sense get along with each other
and I think that's being left out in in
the discussions so I want to try to
reintroduce that so you know the first
point when I when I first saw this story
a few days ago I was like wow that
that's kind of interesting that people
actually got into an argument in Russia
about about Kant and I figured well I've
got all these philosophy colleagues
somebody's gonna be posting about it I
don't need to post about it yeah it just
sort of snowballed and more and more
people kept posting about it making you
know all sorts of funny jokes about it
but nobody seems to have contributed any
sort of illumination of what exactly
took place with these guys we know about
the sequence of events in very broad
strokes these guys are waiting in line
to buy beer apparently at a grocery
store in rostov-on-don and got
themselves into a discussion about [__]
we don't know whether they're friends or
colleagues or you know maybe students
together or whether they just you know
we're guys who happen to start chatting
and eventually the argument got even he
started punching each other and then one
of them whipped down a pissed
started shooting the other one
thankfully it was rubber bullets so
didn't kill him as could have been the
case and then he fled and apparently has
been penny apprehended it could get him
quite a bit of trouble now how did
something like this actually become a
news story that's interesting to reflect
upon you know it became a news story by
cycling through social media by becoming
part of what in some sense is like the
notion of the Republic of Letters that
was so popular in enlightenment times
that the contemn saw was was a part of
and I mean this is something that's
really worth spending a lot of time
discussing and I'm not going to have the
time to go into it here but there's this
notion that you know we often talk about
the marketplace of ideas and in some
respect social media is like that but
marketplaces are where you carry out a
lot of private transactions and there's
not a lot of community being built or
you know meaning being being created in
the Enlightenment they have this
conception of a republic of letters with
you know sort of the educated populace
the literate thinking populace that they
saw is growing and growing and growing
and in some respects historically it
really was becoming closer and closer
not only in mindset and in their
opinions but even in sentiment in habits
in appreciation it was a very humanistic
idea and there's a lot of things really
you know wrong with or problematic about
social media but one thing that is
interesting about it is it does allow
for communication of ideas and in this
case it's about these these two guys you
know duking it out over manual can't in
some southern Russian city which is
quite interesting so the very fact that
this actually becomes a
whose story is I think significant and
worthy of remark upon now these guys
come to blows over a bit of philosophy
and I think you know some of what what
people are reacting to in this is the
idea that somehow philosophers should be
above that sort of thing
now if you spend any time with
philosophers academic professional
philosophers you'll realize that that's
probably true in in large respect that
that they're not going to get in
fistfights very often but that's because
most philosophers at least these days
are pretty set and airy types and tend
to be at least in my experience kind of
timid when it comes to actually
resorting to physical force yeah that's
probably enough to say about that I
would say that quite a few of them are
not you know the bravest people around
there are quite a few of them that have
you know serious anger problems and
would like to get in fights with people
and there are quite a few of them who
you know for one reason or another
do you know really engage in a lot of
martial arts or physical physical things
and you probably won't want to mess with
those people you know particularly if
they're into like Nietzsche or desaad or
you know Thai or somebody somebody who
countenances vile it's George Sorrell
you know but for the most part
philosophers at least these days aren't
aren't into that sort of thing most
academics aren't I think but these guys
weren't philosophers there's nothing
about this story that should suggest
that these two guys were even students
of philosophy let alone professional
philosophers and let's even say that
they were philosophers does that mean
that they won't get into fistfights no
not at all if you look through
history it's funny you know you should
you should read some of the discussions
about philosophers particularly now this
is sort of going over the top but
particularly an allusion of Sammy Sosa
who you know it's this satirist who has
quite a few cases where philosophers
actually you know they go to the same
dinner party and they get into a fight
now they're throwing dishes at each
other or food in each other punching
each other so I mean that sort of thing
did it happen usually it expected to be
a bit more dignified but here's the
thing put all that aside these guys
weren't philosophers is there anything
about being interested in ideas and
being interested in particular in
philosophy that is necessarily going to
to make a person more more tame more
patient less likely to get into into
fistfights or to pull a gun and shoot
rubber bullets at somebody no as a
matter of fact Aristotle Epictetus
plenty of other people but those two i'm
just thinking of in particular because I
remember reading passages them recently
where they were actually talking about
those who study philosophy but don't do
a darn thing with it it doesn't make any
change on their characters because
they're basically interested in learning
the philosophy as a kind of well really
an academic kind of game or something
that they can be proud of in relation to
other people hey I've learned
cruciferous you know epictetus says he
says it doesn't know you're a damn bit
of good if you can't actually apply this
stuff and live a better life Aristotle
says something quite similar in and I
think really anybody could say that sort
of thing there's nothing intrinsically
there's nothing intrinsic about the the
actual text themselves assuming you even
study them and you know crack them open
and think about it that's going to
automatically transform a person into a
more patient
less violent less angry type of
type of being so I think that there is
an assumption there though that we have
a lot of people who have this I think
that's what's part of behind Aristotle's
talk about this hey those people read
these you know books of academic
philosophy and they think it's making
them a better person but it's not making
them a better person why do we have that
notion well I don't know that's
something else that I'd say is worth
exploring as well just having nice laws
just you know surrounding ourselves with
books or talking about ideas doesn't
change our moral character by itself and
may not even have any influence on it it
actually could make us worse because
often times we think that we're better
off than we are when it comes to our
character and our moral capacities and
if we talk about it enough we cycler
sauce into thinking that we're we're
better people so that's kind of an
interesting point yes that's the second
point third point is I find it
fascinating that and also understandable
that these news people are sort of
reporting offhandedly that Russians like
to argue about ideas one of the common
complaints it's made about Americans of
course is that we're anti intellectual
that we're just you know interested in
popular culture or commerce or keeping
up with the the neighbors or you know
things like that then we don't talk
about the big ideas and I don't really
think that's true I think that you know
you travel around the world you find a
lot of people concerned with day to day
occupations or with prestige products
and you know chasing after power or
popularity or things like that and then
you find a lot of other people that are
interested in ideas and so there is
something like a republic of letters
that we we can participate in I'm
willing to believe until I learn
otherwise that
maybe Russians are a bit more interested
in talking about ideas and that's based
solely on sort of anecdotal evidence
coming from reading a lot of Russian
literature which is probably fairly on
representative and on the other hand you
know thinking about Russians who I've
met and other Eastern Europeans who I've
met lieutenant to be pretty interested
in ideas and manage also at the same
time to be quite you know impractical
people when it came to those working at
working with those ideas there is
something kind of good about thinking
you know having this of this this this
picture of people standing in a line
about to buy beer wanting to talk about
cotton or pick anybody else wanting to
talk about Hume wanting to talk about
Cicero wanting to talk about Thomas
Aquinas wanting to talk about all sorts
of you know great thinkers throughout
history wanting to talk about literature
wanting to talk about history not just
wanting to talk about the debt crisis or
you know the cost of meat or who's
winning an American Idol or things like
that there's I kind of like that idea
so not really sure what to do with that
but that's the the third point now let's
talk about contem self and how much what
these guys were doing was completely at
the Antipodes from what Kant actually
stands for and there I think it's worth
talking about the the categorical
imperative which a lot of people have
brought up but I think it's worth kind
of working our way through it this kind
of like what would you what do you would
call a teachable moment it's it's a time
where we can actually see what did this
hot guy think and stand for what did he
contribute to our understanding of
morality and by the way I'm not myself a
couch in I just happen to think that
he's got some interesting ideas and if
these guys themselves were conscience
they may not have been they may have
been arguing about how totally wrong
Kant was and one guy said no he's wrong
for this reason the other guy said he's
wrong for this reason but let's just
assume that they actually thought that
cotton was on the right track well then
we want to look at this notion of the
categorical imperative so the first
version of the categorical imperative
like I put here is act only on the
maximum you can at the same time will to
be a universal law of nature and this is
typically called the universalization
formula because you are talking about
whether you can say something ought to
hold for everybody and the way Kant
understands this is you ought to try to
imagine a world in which everybody is
going to behave according to that that
rule and would it be logically
consistent or would there be logical
contradictions or inconsistencies that
would come up that would mean that you
you shouldn't act that way then you can
also ask can you will it even if it if
it's logically coherent would you be
able to consistently will a world like
that would it make sense to do that so
that is the first formulation of Kant's
categorical imperative which is one of
his you know real major contributions to
morality
now the second formulation which is
often called the humanity formulation is
act R we saw is to treat humanity in
oneself and in others never merely as a
means alone but always as an end and end
in itself and this one is a little bit
harder to get through the terminology at
first but makes is a lot easier to apply
it's saying don't use other people don't
treat them merely as objects to satisfy
one's own desires inclinations
propensity interests treat them as if
they actually possess an inherent
dignity a worth that places them on the
same level as oneself to treat them as a
human being
it also says you're supposed to do this
with yourself as well but that gets a
little bit more complicated and it's
it's really not that important I think
for this particular example so one of
the things that I have noticed when
people talk about the categorical
imperative they throw it around a lot
and these two formulations that that
we've just looked at they apply to this
situation as they would you know any
situation if you're trying to make sense
of this in a conscious manner but what
they require you to do is actually
formulate Maxim's you've got to see what
the general rule that's sort of being
examined being tested being critiqued
being criticized it actually is and when
you're when you're asking about that
you're asking about not just what the
person do why did they do it what was
what was their purpose how did they
conceptualize what they were doing how
would they explain it to another person
yeah again we have to be a little bit
careful with this case because we we
don't have you know the capacity to peer
inside the heads of these these two
bruisers who got into the fight but I
think we can you know we can say look if
they're they're fairly rational people
they weren't just like fighting with the
demon
their heads or something like that they
probably you know ran through some sort
of lines of reasoning sort of like this
so let's think about each one of these
in turn and then see what we would do in
terms of the the formulations of the
categorical imperative the ones that
we've looked at so far so when I find
myself in disagreement with another
person I will argue my case to them
makes sense that's I think that's
reasonable enough and that's what we do
when we actually disagree about things
we you know sometimes we don't even go
that far sometimes you say well let's
agree to disagree or I'm not going to
talk about it because you know better
not get into an argument about this or
thing get heated you know maybe it's not
the right time but if it's okay if you
know there isn't any other thing
standing in the way duty wise as far as
common would say you know this is
probably good enough and then how did it
escalate well maybe some of these other
Maxim's were involved when a person when
I believe a person I am arguing with is
wrong I will become angry with that
person that's an interesting way to
think about this usually when we're
talking about nobody wants to bring up
the emotions at all other than just
otherwise you know to say just don't
follow any emotions don't get emotional
right but these guys seem to think that
it was okay to get angry can we look at
that from a Content perspective when I
become angry with an interlock that are
in argument I will resort to force and
we could ask why why did these guys
start you know boxing with each other or
fighting with each other was it just
because of the anger where they tried
what did they see this as a way to
persuade the other person hey I'm right
I'm going to impose this interpretation
of contour against contour whatever it
was that they're arguing about on the
other person and then finally when I'm
involved in an argument that turns
violent I will use greater though not
deadly
because he used rubber bullets force
each one of these would be a maxim that
if you would like to look inside of the
structure of motivation and choice and
action on the part of these two guys or
at least you know the one the last one
one of these guys you can say that's
what that's what they were up to so
let's think about this when I find
myself in disagreement with another
person I will argue my case to them can
you can you make that a universal law of
nature can you say everybody when they
are in a situation where they find
themselves in disagreement with another
person they will argue the case for for
what it is that they think is the right
thing yeah I think you can make that a
universal law of nature I think you
could even willed that it makes sense to
that's a rational way of trying to
resolve differences and to convince
people that we think are actually
off-base that makes a good sense you
know we can also go a little bit further
with it and say when I find myself in
disagreement with another person I will
argue my case of them and I will listen
as objectively as possible to their case
totally universe I have a universal
izybelle right you can say yeah that's
the way the world should work it'd be a
much better world if people did do that
there's nothing logically incoherent
about saying that you can will it it
makes good sense another thing to think
about with that is you're also treating
the other person as you know the
humanity in the other person he has an
end your if you're trying to rationally
convince another person you're trying to
give them evidence or trying to give
them reasons to to accept your point of
view and if you're willing to listen to
them and be open to to being convinced
of their point of view you're completely
treating them as an end you know you're
treating them with human dignity you're
not simply reducing
so so far so good
what about the second one when I believe
a person I'm arguing with is wrong I
will become angry with that person can
you universalize that can you imagine a
world in which every time that somebody
gets angry with another person they hate
that every time that a person disagrees
with another person they have to become
angry with that person there's nothing
logically incoherent or contradictory
about such a world you can imagine such
a world would it make sense to will such
a world know so it actually fails the
the first formulation of the categorical
imperative not because it can't be
universalized but because you it
wouldn't make sense to will that kind of
world so what that reveals to us is that
we actually have an imperfect duty a
broad duty not to get angry with people
with whom were engaged in argument or
disagreement likewise we can say well
they they have a similar duty with
respect to us not to get angry at us are
you treating those ones the second
formulation are you treating a person as
a means and not an end
if you become angry with that person it
really depends on the grounds of the
anger doesn't it if you're getting angry
with the person simply because they're
contradicting you or because you don't
like being wrong yes then I think
actually by allowing yourself to become
angry with them especially if you're
acting on the anger you are treating
them as a means to the satisfaction of
your desires your inclinations one of
which is to wanting to be right if
you're angry with the other person
because it really bothers you that they
are stuck in being wrong
and you know that they're wrong or at
least you feel you know that they're
they're wrong hmm
one might say in a case like that that
you are respecting the other person but
you really have to be careful from a
Content perspective you know there's
there's a difference between knowing
that the other person is is wrong and
that it's bad for them to be wrong about
this this sort of thing and thinking
that to be the case feeling that to be
the case but not actually knowing that
to be the case
we're often paternalistic with each
other we want to remove the obstacles
the stumbling blocks to other people's
understanding but sometimes when we do
that we don't actually know what we're
talking about so you've got to be a
little bit careful with that you could
be treating the other person is as
merely a means to your vision of the way
things ought to be
let's move on to the next when I become
angry with an interlocutor an argument I
will resort to force
can you universalize this I would say no
and just off-the-cuff the reason I would
say no is if you're engaged in argument
once you leave argument behind it and
decide to resort to force in order to
make your points you're going against
the whole purpose of argument which is
to produce rational conviction in
another human being so there there is
some sort of you know logical
incoherence at least or performative
contradiction in what you're doing you
could actually leave the the become
angry part out of that what if we focus
on the becoming angry because I'm angry
I will use force against another person
that you really can't universalize
either I mean now here's where I would
actually probably did differ from cut
for cut it's not supposed to be about
the consequences it's supposed to be
just about the
action itself and whether it you know
sort of logically coherent for me it
doesn't make sense to say we ought to
all follow what anger wants from us
because anger is by its own nature
here's an Aristotelian point if not
irrational completely irrational at
least it doesn't listen to reason as it
should to the degree that it should
Aristotle calls it like a hasty servant
who listens to half the instructions and
then runs off and then watches the job
so I don't think we would we would
universalize that certainly we could you
know once we get to the point of can we
will it no you cannot will that every
time a person gets angry they should
resort to force let's think about the
humanity formula they become anger is
somebody you're going to resort to force
to convince them or it you know just to
indulge your anger to to vent it upon
them you are treating that person that's
just a means to an end but and then that
has to do with your own satisfaction
whether you're you're just venting and
you know attacking them because you you
want to feel what anger you know is
pushing you towards the satisfaction of
imposing something on them or you want
to try to convince them but you're doing
it out just out of anger you are
treating them as just an I mean not not
as an valuable in it so the other if you
didn't treat them as an end valuable in
itself
you wouldn't punch them in the nose
right what about the last one when I'm
involved in an argument that turns
violent so two people are using force
against each other I will use greater no
not deadly force so there's some
restraint there can you know
universalize this no you can't utilize
that I'm going to escalate the the level
of force force is already being used
force ought to be used in measured
amounts force ought to be used basically
to resolve situations not to make them
worse somebody
like hunt would say for me to decide you
know it's not like I'm you know a police
officer measuring out the amount of
force thinking this is actually going to
serve you know the larger society I'm
acting as a private citizen I'm not
being threatened with deadly force
myself
I'm escalating the level of force no
that can't be universalized even if it
could and I don't think I can there's no
way you would will that so when you're
doing that what about the humanity
formula second formulation of the
categorical imperative I think in that
case to you are actually treating that
person as a means to an end whatever it
is that you're trying to accomplish a
resolution to the situation and your own
safety
by raising the level of force when they
haven't actually threatened deadly force
you're treating them as a mere means to
an end so that's what's going on in this
situation that's how I think hot would
actually look at all of this the fifth
thing that I I want to talk about that
gets brought up at least for me by this
this little fracas and in rostov-on-don
over catchy and philosophy perhaps
fueled by by beer we don't really know
is that cat has other really interesting
things to say about about this sort of
this sort of thing and it doesn't have
to do so much with the categorical
imperative as such and more to do with
other conceptions having to do with duty
with what we call broader imperfect
duties and with the emotions and the
passions and the ways those sort of
things work now Kant wrote this book the
groundwork that the categorical
imperative is coming the groundwork for
the metaphysics of morals
and usually people sort of stop short
they're in their study of cod and that
was also supposed to be tied in with the
second critique which is a lot again
unless you're a philosopher perhaps a
political theorist or there's a few
other fields you probably don't read
that it's worth reading the actual
metaphysics of morals because cat says a
lot of really interesting
connect-the-dots kind of stuff in in
that work and he also says things about
this these sorts of topics in another
work called anthropology from a
pragmatic point of view now cut was all
about reason is over here and reason
ought to determine you know how we we
should behave and the the passions the
emotions the sentiments all the
affective things are over here except
for moral feeling of that that's kind of
a weird thing that we you know to talk
about some other time and then the will
is right there smack dab in the middle
and the will can go this way or the will
can go this way if it goes this way even
if it does the right thing it's doing it
for the wrong reasons
and so it's it's actions it's choices
are without moral value it's only when
the will wills
rationally objectively universally you
know the categorical imperative fits in
with that doing duty for its own sake
that that you have moral value in what
the will is determining and what the
person is is choosing to do and what
they in fact do now that doesn't mean
that there's no value whatsoever in
emotion but in general emotion and
passion is going to be be a problem for
cut and there's certain determinate ways
in which this this works itself out
so let's actually look at a few things I
picked out a few interesting portions
where he talks about this sort of stuff
the first thing I want to I want to hit
on is this notion of a broad or
or relaxed or imperfect duty a lot of
times people will frame perfect' duties
versus imperfect duties as well perfect
duties are the ones you have to do and
imperfect duties are the ones that you
don't have to do but you're a better
person if you do that it's better to not
to do them than to not do them well
you're not required to do them so it's
up to you cut talks that way sometimes
but but really when it comes down to it
the way that he sees is no you do have a
duty to do the imperfect duties it's
just that the perfect duties supersede
them he says by a broad duty is not
understood of permission to make
exceptions to the maxim of the actions
but only the permission to limits ones
maximum Duty by another so for example
the general love of one's neighbor which
is an imperfect duty by the love of
one's parents which you have a stronger
duty towards I says the broader the duty
the more imperfect therefore in what is
one's obligation to the action now what
makes us good people is being virtuous
and being virtuous means being the kind
of person who actually does those
imperfect duties and chooses to do them
even when we don't we don't have to you
know it's sort of reflected in our
choices over time you can say says the
strength of purpose and such fulfillment
is a long properly called virtue
deliberate transgression on the other
hand that has become a principle
properly constitutes what's called vice
so if we want to think about are these
guys vicious now again we don't know
that much about it so we're gonna have
to proceed kind of hypothetically but
you know we can say certain things based
on what Kant says about about emotions
and passions so here's what he says
about those emotions and passions are
essentially distinct emotions belong to
feeling which proceeding reflection as
it does makes reflection more differ
even impossible so you know you feel
excited you're having a harder time
concentrating on things you feel
surprised for a moment you can't
actually think about things you feel sad
that makes it difficult for you to think
about non sad things and attend other
you know details of the situation and
think things out you feel desirous of
something that can get in the way you
feel angry those are sort of momentary
things that pop up in history so he says
the motion is therefore called hasty or
precipitate and reason declares through
the concept concept of virtue that a man
should collect himself so to be virtuous
for Kant means to try not to be affected
by by these emotions or when you do get
affected by them don't let them run the
show don't let them you know change how
you ought to think about things
so he says nevertheless this weakness is
the use of one's understand the use of
one's understanding join with the
strength of the agitation is only a lack
of virtue and as it were something we
can childish it can be consistent with
the best will and moreover as one good
point than its storm students of size so
a propensity towards emotion for example
anger is therefore not so closely
related to vice as passion is so here
we're going to have a big distinction
passion II says is the sensible appetite
grown into a lasting inclination for
example hatred as in contrast to it to
anger he says the calmness with which
one indulges passions permits reflection
allows the mind to frame principles for
it now I don't think we can take that as
applying to all passionless whatever the
basic point is that that passion is
where something has become a ritual it's
become part of our our character it
forms part of the manifold of what he
calls inclinations and it can provoke
desires that continue on so what are
these guys involved in it's difficult to
say what exactly their emotional basis
is because we don't know much about them
but let's just assume that they were
angry and
maybe that anger you know rose to the
level that it did because it wasn't just
something that that you know pops up
once in awhile for these guys but these
guys are actually prone to anger and
prone to you know getting into two
fights and big disagreements and stuff
like that so can't talks about you know
malice and making fun of people and you
know he calls this mockery you know like
like minded fault finding the propensity
to expose other people to ridicule or
derision involved in making another
person's fault the immediate object of
one's amusement is spite he says
entirely different from joking or making
fun of apparent false well in the
intimacy of one's friends why well
because you're like trying to hurt the
other person you're trying to get at
them and God seems to think that this
this can become you know very very
ingrained in a person he also talked
about as towards the end of the the
elements of ethics the what he calls the
social virtues or the you know the ones
that we need in in social what he calls
social intercourse when we're discussing
things with other people and you know
what does this boil down to well you
know being polite with other people
sometimes it means like letting the
other person think that they they won
the argument even though they didn't
make very good points that's probably
something that could be useful in this
this this this altercation that took
place Kahn talks about it this way says
it's one's duty both to himself and to
others to use his moral perfection in
social intercourse and not isolate
himself to be sure a person must make
himself the immovable center of his
principles but nevertheless he must
regard as fear as part of an
all-encompassing sphere of Cosmopolitan
sentiment not so much in order to
promote the good of the world as to
cultivate those really interesting
cultivate the means that lead indirectly
to it namely the agreeableness of
society
sociability mutual love and respect
affability and propriety and so the
graces will accompany virtue it is even
a duty he says to bring this about so
these guys failed in a broad number of
duties you know they when they started
getting angry they had a duty to like
you know collect themselves and not
allow the natural tendencies that we
have to you know lead them into to
getting you know more and more heated
and perhaps trading insults making fun
of each other who knows exactly what
went on can't seize this sort of thing
you know it's now it's I mean I did get
quite quite you know dangerous another
one guy shot at another guy thankfully
it was rubber bullets but you didn't he
didn't kill him but kind of say you know
these little things they actually matter
they they are important the way in which
we deal with our emotions and our
passions is is very important yeah in
the Anthropology from a pragmatic point
of view it was a great pass at
charrisse's passions are cancerous
stores for pure practical reason most of
them are incurable because the sick
person does not want to be cured and
avoids the Dominion of the principle by
which alone a cure could be effected you
know when somebody actually is vicious
it's tough for them to act to admit that
and they'll try to rationalize the way
in which they behave in all sorts of
manners and even when they said you have
got a problem oftentimes they don't want
to put in the work to change that kind
of let's say that we have an obligation
to do that so you know if I'm gonna
bring this to a close I mean you know
yeah what does all this mean right
you're a philosopher tell me give me
something that I can take home as a
lesson about this well I would say that
this is a great time to remind ourselves
that when we're engaged in discussion
about ideas that matter we should
realize that if these are really our
ideas at man
we're not going to begin from a point of
agreement with most people and we should
be really happy when we find ourselves
in agreement and when we find ourselves
in disagreement we should try not to
take it personally we should watch out
for our emotions getting engaged or even
worse you know our our our vices are
what Kant calls passions getting engaged
the ones that bear on emotion I'm more
of a Sicilian than conscient in this
respect but that's that's a total aside
yeah we should try to you know still
look at the other person as having some
value even if we think they're totally
dead wrong
we should there's certain things that we
shouldn't do and those don't just
include not punching them in the face or
pulling a gun on them and shooting them
up but even talking to them in certain
ways so and this is a lesson that it's
taken me a long time to learn and I
didn't learn it from Comte I learned it
from from the school of hard knocks and
reflection and remorse and thinking
about people like epictetus and
Aristotle rather than Conte
but I think God could teach us that
lesson too and I think that's what what
we ought to take from from this whole
episode